اهلا بكم البدايه باخر التطورات المدنيه
في اوكرانيا حيث افادت هيئه الاركان
العامه الاوكرانيه بصد اكثر من 100 هجوم
الروسي في اتجاهات باخموت
ومارينكا وشختار شرقي البلاد واضافه
الهيئه وان البلاد تعرضت لنحو 30 غاره
جويه ومئه هجوم براجمات الصواريخ وكشفت ان
الروس استهدفوا منطقه دوناتسك بهجمات
صاروخيه موجهه فضلا عن هجمات باستخدام
الراجمات واكدت الهيئه استمرار القوات
الروسيه في محاولاتها للوصول الى الحدود
الاداريه
لمنطقتي دونتسك
في المقابل اعلنت القوه الاوكرانيه تنفيذ
الطائرات الحربيه الاوكرانيه احدى عشره
غاره على مناطق تمركز القوات الروسيه وضرب
موقع لمنظومه الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات
واسقاط طائره مسيره